salut une nouvelle mission d'agent
secret comme vous avez bien aimé le
concept et moi aussi et bien maintenant
je vais enchaîner les missions d'agents
secrets comme ça régulièrement donc
aujourd'hui
excuse moi excuse moi ça c'est alerte
intro trop longue alerte on doit y aller
alerte la mission commence on y va c'est
parti ok j'arrête
on y va
[Musique]
changement de t-shirts de coupe de
cheveux et de rasage pour vous prévenir
buzz plutôt d'une bonne nouvelle en fait
c'est un partenariat avec audible mais
que vous allez aimer
en tout cas audible sponsorise cette
vidéo et c'est plutôt une très bonne
nouvelle si vous connaissez pas si une
application audible application vous
allez trouver principalement des livres
audio des séries audio et des potters
applications avec un catalogue très
fourni de plus de 400 mille titres dans
plein de langues différentes
on y trouve de tout par exemple on y
trouve tous mes livres
en audio enregistrée par ma voix depuis
quelques années alors comment ça se
passe là genre mon avant dernier livre
votre temps est infini craque je le
redis sera en audio ça devenait ceci ce
petit format très agréable qui a donné
paf exactement ça c'est à dire la
version audio / audible c'est le cas
aussi pour mon premier livre votre
cerveau est extraordinaire car
directement sur audible et ça va être le
cas ce mois ci avec mon dernier livre le
bonheur est caché dans un coin de votre
cerveau quand on a enregistré en
novembre décembre et qui sort ce mois-ci
aussi sur l'appli alors comment ça
marche
audible en fait c'est une appli qui
fonctionne avec un abonnement de 9,95
par mois et tous les mois vous avez un
jeton pour un titre audio de votre choix
n'importe lequel
l'abonnement est résiliable à n'importe
quel moment et c'est là où ça va vous
intéresser qu en passant par mon lien
qui a dans la description vous avez deux
mois gratuits au lieu d'un en gros vous
allez avoir deux titres audio gratuit
ce que vous voulez et si au bout des
deux mois et de vos deux titres gratuits
vous voulez résidiez hebei a pas de
souci et pas d'engagement donc si vous
voulez avoir mes livres audio
gratuitement baisser le temps vous
passez par le lien de la description et
puis avec vos deux jetons vous prenez le
bonheur à cacher dans un coin de notre
cerveau ou votre temps est infini où mon
premier livre cerveau est extraordinaire
et comme ça se passait bien vous les
avez choix en va de l'homme on peut pas
faire mieux que gratuit à un moment
donné les gars ben quoi
un peu d'argent pour que tu chies bas je
mets un billet de 5 euros dans les
livres audio
mais du coup c'est 5 euros de billets
que tu entends ce que je peux frotter à
ça c'est pas mal merci audible d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo et merci d'avoir
créé cette offre là pour les deux mois
gratuits en passant par mon lien je suis
très content qu'on puisse faire ça voilà
ça doit se voir à jean fabien alias
agent fabu vous avez passé votre test
d'aptitude agent secret de la réussite
du coup ça veut dire vous l'avez russie
c'est votre première mission au quai
tout se trouve là dedans
la boîte aux lettres de l'oncle ben
pourquoi que l'oncle ben dedans il ya du
rythme n'est pas dieu riposte c'est très
fort
j'ai pris également au moins un gallon
tout se trouve là dedans toutes les
informations nécessaires au bon
développement et au déroulement de cette
mission d'accord ok pourrir cette boîte
vous avez besoin de cette clé pour
obtenir cette clé faut répondre répondre
à une énigme
cette clément de quelle nationalité et
elle bat les suisses parce que parce que
le lac léman lac léman bien vu allez-y
c'est c'est ça c'est ce que lac léman
je vous en prie rester là juste pour
voir si tout se passe bien ça me met la
pression
edf taxe d'habitation réclamations des
suisses pour une blague nul sur le lac
léman
ok donc là tout ce qui est là dedans
monsieur au lit car vous servira à votre
mission d'accord je garde pas la clé par
tenant la cuisse étrange ouvrage attendu
de ses parents qu'est ce qu'on va faire
si vous avez vous placez là bas
d'accord vous allez commencer la mission
que vous allez retourner à votre
ouverture celle vous êtes un vendeur de
rue entre deux missions sa copieuse dans
les sociétés devant des canapés moi non
ok ah bon bon courage bon courage mon
corps est bon courage pour quoi c'est
une bonne couverture
ça m'a l'air top secret
un chauffage d'appoint comme vous en
prie c est vous on va commencer par ceux
ci je pense que ça ça permet de voyager
dans le temps afin de parler à ces gens
là c'est pas si loin vous n'êtes pas si
loin d'un prix top secret c'est parti
agent fabu je me reconnais sur ce nom
vous avez récemment passé avec succès le
test de recrutement auprès de la gente
elle fait donc désormais officiellement
partie du cercle très fermé des agents
secrets votre première mission si vous
l'acceptez et je ne l'acceptent jeu
l'accès sans condition je m'y engage
quoi qu'il en coûte sera d'associer les
voix de six suspects c'est dégueulasse
un suspect ainsi profils différents
pour cela vous aurez à votre disposition
des cassettes audio avec les voix des
suspects associer les eaux bonnes photos
pour vous aider dans votre tâche vous
pourrez consulter des vidéos muette des
suspects et si vraiment vous galérez
votre mère je vraiment je lis calme
marquée si vous galérez votre mère c'est
vraiment un langage codé d'agents
secrets vous pourrez consulter des
indices classés secret défense
pour toute question tournez vous vers
l'agent elle il n'aura probablement pas
la réponse mais pourra vous soutenir
d'un regard appuyé vous faire un câlin
du coude
je vous souhaite bon courage à jean fait
beaucoup et que la force d agent secret
soit avec vous signés l'agent dont nous
ne doit pas prononcer le nom
merci de jeter ce message dans la
poubelle approprié du coup est ce que la
poubelle s'autodétruit donc ici dans l'
enveloppe numéro il n'y a pas de numéro
j'ai deux indices et une cassette de
monsieur l'habite
je crois qu'il s'appelle jean l'abidjan
un suis ici c'est joli c'est jolie
madame michaud je sais pas qui a préparé
cette mission mais vraiment il ya du
level ici j'ai monsieur cocu
je pense que c'est des vrais noms de
familles de ces gens et qui faisait
genre un témoignage à la c'est mon choix
des années 80 de bonjour je m'appelle
madame michon et c'est pas facile à
porter comme non je suis sûr que c'est
ça et monsieur bordel non mais je suis
surtout là où vrai nom ici j'ai un petit
ipad
donc ça ça doit être les vidéos muet ok
donc ça c'est des vidéos cinq sont que
je vois ces gens parlent et comprendre
si c'est pas elle-même un agent que
déguisé quand même j'ai un doute
j'ai déjà trié les hommes des femmes je
mette monsieur l'habite
sous monsieur cocu et je vais mettre le
gros monsieur bordel part au dessus
parce que c'est le bordel je vais
commencer par mesdames nichons
frankenstein et la cuisse commençant par
madame michon vous pouvez noter dans des
commentaires quand même la qualité de la
préparation cette vidéo merci à toute
l'équipe car c'est fort sympathique je
vais la mettre dans n'importe quel sens
madame nichons et j'appuie sur la touche
rembobinez michon c'est dur porté à fait
clair parce que j'ai bien vu qu'il y
avait une enceinte connectés que c'est
pas ça qui fait du bruit nichons c'est
dur à porter non pas du tout vous avez
connu de nom de votre mari tout de suite
non mon mari m'a avoué qu'il s'appelait
niche en quelques jours seulement avant
notre mariage
un jour j'étais dans un bureau d pt et
j'arrive au guichet que je donne mon
papier
il y avait là une employée très grosse
avec une poitrine énorme posé sur le
comptoir
c'était peut-être madame michu madame
lichon pour l'instant je vais théorisée
comme ça je sais pas si j'ai le droit de
le faire mais par rapport à l'âge de la
voix je la mettrais bien ici minami
chant et je vais regarder un peu sur la
vidéo ce que ça donne elle coûterait
contracté parce qu'elle avait la voix
très dans la gorge elle quand elle
parlait et elle avait des fins de
phrases comme ça où elles reprenaient un
peu d'air
je trouve que ça match pas trop mal je
gardais madame nichons là dessus pour le
moment
n'hésitez pas vous aussi dans les
commentaires à me dire un peu quel est
votre théorie on passe ce test ensemble
on est une équipe on va se tenter un
petit madame la cuisse quand même madame
la cuisse plus ou moins oui je préfère
préciser quelque chose ou est ce qu'il
n'y ait aucune ambiguïté les vidéos que
vous venez de visionner ça ne correspond
pas aux sons que vous entendez oui ça je
reste non mais je préfère le dire parce
que les gens on peut dire oui
madame nichons oui nichons alors que ce
n'est pas le cas pourquoi vous êtes vous
originaire de la pupille mis son nom
mais je préfère préciser pourquoi pas
nombreux ils d'accord mais pas
d'ambiguïté sur secret aller là bas non
au revoir la commune madame la cuisse
quand j'étais petit jeu on a passé un
test pour se sélectionner pour les
championnats d'académie parce que je
faisais beaucoup de sport
il y avait une quarantaine de petites
filles à peu près et on nous appelait
dans les starting blocks et 1,60 m
j'avais 12 ans à peu près et le monsieur
ali la cuisse les 40 petit fils se sont
mis à rire j'ai gagné la course g il y
avait une fille qui deuxième battre
parce qu'elle qu'on va beaucoup plus
vite comme moi je les écraser j'étais
dans une rage folle
on imagine vittel sourire et surtout
quand elle parle des fois ça m'aide et
demi ton en bas donc il imagine bien
comme cette vidéo là on voit la personne
kif qui souvent parle comme ça est fini
comme ça et on voit qu'on baisse un
petit peu un ton quand on descend du
coup je théorise ici sur elle pour
madame la couille peut-être celle-ci
peut-être je regarderai les indices
après avant de avant de pourvoir
madame frankenstein et si ciel on
pourrait dire ces voix grave
automatiquement mais on n'est pas sûr
pourtant que je crois qu'elle parle
plutôt la front de gauche quel type de
blagues nous fêtons le téléphone le
téléphone et c'est ça m'en ont été des
soins en pleine nuit ou
vous appelle de 3 heures du matin bon je
me précipite comme une folle pensant
qu'il ya quelque chose d'important et
j'entends à lomagne frankenstein
bon je réponds oui ici dracula arabes
quand vous raccroche au nez bon ben ça
c'est ces courants on entend ça au moins
je sais pas de trois fois par semaine
j'hésite avec madame michaud comme elle
ok ça c'est ma première théorie c'est ce
serait ça pour moi les femmes pour
l'instant je théorie sur madame
frankenstein en un
madame michaud en deux et banham la
cuisse en trois mais je me demande si
elle l aurait pas un défaut de
prononciation à la base peut-être zoomer
ou pas elle a souvent la langue qui
bloque sur les dents je verrai écoutez
madame la cuisse pour voir ce comment
elle prononce crs qui allait prononcer
un peu plus un peu plus mouillé on
appelle ça on appelle ça le buggy laisse
alors quand j'étais petit jeu on a passé
un test pour se sélectionner pour les
championnats d'académie parce que je
faisais beaucoup de sport
il y avait une quarantaine de petites
filles à peu près et on nous appelait
dans les starting blocks et 1,60 m
j'avais 10 12 ans à peu près à la ds un
peu mouillé quand même c'est possible
que ce soit elle que je vais faire je
vais prendre un indice sur madame
michaud comme ça pour voir si je bouge
quelque chose ou pas ça ou c'est mon
premier j'ai comme ça à l'arraché dites
moi si vous êtes d'accord avec moi ou
pas pour pour pour le côté femme mais on
va voir
indice numéro 1 qui j'imagine est moins
fort kémaliste numéro de madame michon a
des yeux
voilà voilà que ça voudrait dire qu'elle
a déminé que les autres n'ont pas de
lunettes et que ça veut dire c'est des
gros yeux
ou est-ce que juste en se fout de ma
gueule le 12 10 je vais dans le tester
'l'indice de madame frankenstein pour
voir en fait je cherche à confirmer ce
que j'aimais indice numéro un 30-15
stein porte un collier à bas sont que
deux à avoir un collier il ya elle est l
ok bon je vais me contenter de ça alors
j'ai pas ouvrir d'un lit sans plus pour
le moment
comme ça je valide sa pour le moment où
on va si j'ai faux après je demanderai à
l'agent elle de me laisser faire des
modifs en regardant les indices probable
on passe à monsieur bordel les voix
d'hommes c'est plus compliqué bordel
c'est un nom difficile à porter pour moi
très pénible pourquoi parce que dure
depuis mon enfance on va j'ai entendu
que des quolibets sur comment s'est
passé votre scolarité assez mal surtout
à partir de 12 ans parce que j'ai déjà
su à peu près là signifie que la
singularité de mon nom sans en
comprendre bien le sens comment vous
vous défendez soit par l'ironie ou soit
par le silence
et puis des fois ça blesse on a une voix
qui remonte légèrement dans le nez et
puis si je regarde ces vidéos là je
trouve que la position sa position quand
il parle ça fonctionne avec dans la
prose odile un truc de d'envoyer comme
ça et c'est un peu ce qu'il fait avec sa
tête
oui peut-être ce serait lui monsieur
monsieur bordel
imaginons que lui se sommes là c'est
juste une hypothèse pour lancer un peu
de game coins on va voir ce qu'en dit
monsieur cocu pourquoi celui du milieu
je vois bien monsieur la [ __ ] mais
vraiment un sens alors pourquoi monsieur
cocu caucus est dur à porter pas
vraiment
quand votre femme a connu votre nom est
ce qu'il a été surprise au premier abord
vous premier rapport est ensuite d'après
touché
pourquoi vous enfants ont-ils changé de
nom et bien comme ayant fait des études
supérieures à lille ont atteint des
postes de cadres et à reste c'est à dire
en responsabilité je crois que pour eux
c'était mieux
c'est difficile d'être cadrée de
s'appeler cocu je crois je crois alors
lâchez pas dû je ne sais pas ce que vous
en pensez mais alors moi je sais rien
qui correspond même quand je les vois
parler
j'ai peut-être inverser bordel est plus
qu on va tester la [ __ ] ce que des fois
cette rue est la [ __ ] qui débloque
mais je la sens bien la [ __ ] l'habite
c'est un nom difficile à porter haut le
nom de lavit oui c'est pas très facile à
porter enfin
qu'on supporte très facilement ce nom
quand on est adulte c'est beaucoup de
c'était beaucoup plus difficile si vous
voulez quand j'étais beaucoup plus jeune
j'étais enfant scolaire etc
c'est beaucoup plus difficile je suis
arrivé à l'armée la chambre et on est
tous passés par là j'aurais donné un
laps de temps ces derbys jour je leur ai
dit pendant huit jours bon ben voila je
m'appelle la [ __ ] vous vous amusez vous
faites tout ce que vous voulez mais dans
huit jours ça sera terminé pour les
entoure votre souhait après ça sera fini
et puis au bout de neuvième jour je
crois est un petit malin qui a trouvé
drôle de continuer les plaisanteries
alors il a été faire un petit stage à
l'infirmerie
lui c'est lui qui témoignent de la plus
grande carrure visage le plus car est
aussi et de la voie la plus jeune du
coup je pense que la [ __ ] c'est lui par
contre bordel du coup me demande si
c'est pas lui
et du coup ça me mettrait cocu ici je
verrai écouter cocu pour voir un petit
peu ce que ça donne c'est pas mal comme
expérience
cocu je pense que ce caucus est dur à
porter pas vraiment
quand votre femme a connu votre nom
est-ce qu'elle a été surprise 6 premiers
rapports oui premier rapport est aussi
le bouche un peu fermé comme il parle un
petit peu resserré je regardais au
niveau des lèvres et on voit ces
commissions elles sont toujours à touche
touche et je trouve que ça marche quand
même voici ma théorie pour les garçons
bordel l'habite cocu je vais regarder un
indice sur cocu et si ça confirme un
petit peu ne serait ce qu'un petit peu
j'appellerai l'agent elle monsieur cocu
ce qu'on va me dire il a il est assis
monsieur cocu à une cravate
ça confirme disney world
les deux je pense qu'ils sont un peu
plus forts du coup je vais je vais
regarder que de ladite numéro un 10
numéros 1 2
de bordel peut-être si le bordel et
dégarnis on peut dire que c'est
dégarnissant vrai c'est quand même
dégarni super mois quand même ce qu'ils
veulent faire passer un message que ce
serait moi qui fout le bordel j'ai pas
de cravate
en même temps je suis pas monsieur
contenu j'espère je vais valider ça je
veux faire venir là joël sur ma première
proposition sans user trop les indices
si vous voulez faire vos pronostics
vous aussi vous les mettez maintenant
comment dans la description
je vous rappelle que les vidéos vous
avez vu ce ne sont pas les moments où
ils sont en train de dire ce qu'on
entendait donc on peut pas comparer avec
le labiale heureusement sinon ce ne
serait pas très pieux mais c'est
incroyable vous êtes kurita alors
qu'est-ce que vous validez la benne
l'ensemble du tableau ouais ouais ouais
c'est machado sur la gauche sur le bas
surtout validé tous leurs tout cas où
quoi je teste quoi sur l'ensemble du
tableau il ya quatre bonnes réponses
nokia une inversion est ce que vous
voulez qu'on aille plus loin
agent fabu et que on valide des choses
wallon valley pas et vous repartez vous
alors non non non on va rester comme ça
je vais je vais je vais peut-être aller
taper un peu dans les indices port
d'accord par contre ça que nouvel indice
c'est une pichenette démonstration d'une
pichenette pour savoir à peu près ce qui
m'attend c'est raisonnable c'est juste
pour ajouter du foot et du fun ok bah je
sais pas s'il y avait du fun il y avait
un feat
mais je passe y est beaucoup plus
coûteux fais ok une pichenette
ok ok aussi un bon chercheur parti alors
je vais en prendre les dossiers hommes
parce que pour moi c'est là je dis quel
bordel on fait appel à moi si besoin est
monsieur l'habite monsieur l'a vite je
suis sûr que c'est lui du coup je vais
regarder un indice pour monsieur la vie
sociale habite n'a pas tous moustache
pas mal pas de moustache et sur qui j'ai
pas prix de langeais pris un indice sur
les trois hommes
moi je suis sûr de monsieur n'habite bon
monsieur cocu et une cravate là c'était
pas un vrai indices alors regardons
indice numéro 2 et j'essaie de me
débrouiller avec ça ah [ __ ] ce
monsieur qu'aucune a pas de bulletin
j'avais bon au départ et j'ai inversé la
donc si j'avais quatre bonnes réponses
c'est forcément ça monsieur générique
agents l agent l agent elle
agen bon je suis arrivé j'étais un ami
sur justement à berlin donc je viendrai
glaciaire d'où l'accent nous nous avons
trouvé nous avons eu un indice assez
violent nous dit monsieur qu'aucune
n'avait pas de lunettes
ça fait moins ça quand même c'est vrai
mais sur quel barème de points c'est un
secret j'avais fait un barème d'agents
secrets du coup lorsqu'on a bon partout
eh bien on va avoir la preuve en images
toutes premières idées pour les gens
quand on entend le mot frankenstein ça
fait tout de suite le monstre alors que
ce n'est pas le monstre c'est benoît lui
du docteur qui est le créateur de du
monstre en réalité ok donc l en avant l
on a bon passons ensuite à madame
nichons donc on était plus dans le nez
et surtout on avait une petite vibration
du halage et comme c'était la plus
vieille nichons c'est dur à porter non
pas du tout vous avez connu de nom de
votre mari tout de suite non mon mari
m'a avoué qu'il s'appelait niche en
quelques jours seulement avant notre
mariage
même la cuy troisième validation du coup
qu'ils avaient la voie la plus franche
en fait en terme d'énergie et ça
marchait bien aussi avec son label et
les f1 peu mouillé les femmes es un peu
mouillé mais de toute façon je pense que
on n'a pas trop le choix j'étais petit
jeu on a passé un test pour se
sélectionner pour les championnats
d'académie
il a d'ailleurs l'habitude de parler en
public un comme on peut le voir passant
monsieur cocu alors qu'il m'a posé tant
de mal au cul c'est dur à porter est-ce
qu'elle a été surprise du premier abord
oui premier rapport est ensuite un comme
garder les lèvres ouverte lançant je le
voyais pas avoir genevois car monaco
ouais le 6e bajeux bien écouté la voix
du cices du coup parce que lui il avait
les commissures heureux comme ça avec sa
femme monsieur madame bordel c'est un
nom difficile à porter pour moi très
pénible pourquoi quand il en parle
depuis mon enfance on va j'ai entendu
que des quolibets sur seulement comment
s'est passé votre scolarité chez mal
surtout à partir de 12 ans il me fait de
la peine
et alors monsieur l'habite
non monsieur d'avis que lui il avait un
côté je suis gaillacois et comme on
voyait qu'il a aidé large d'épaulés on
voit il est grand et les costauds et
comme il parlait d'avoir envoyé un mec à
l'infirmerie en étant à l'armée la [ __ ]
c'est un nom difficile à porter haut le
nom de la ville oui c'est pas très
facile à porter la félicitations à jean
fabre merci beaucoup mire mission
réussie première mission ici première
mission pas si dur bah je sais noter je
veux dire la prochaine fois c'est noté
après spa mois décidée c'est à tous les
agents secrets qui nous écoutent
sûrement en secret est-ce qu'on se fait
mission plus difficile qui n'a rien à
voir dans le prochain épisode
ou est-ce qu'on fait une mission plus
difficile un jour aussi avec gc pas
moins dix personnes par exemple ou 12 ou
ou 28 qu'est ce que j'ai gagné du coup
en tant qu'adjointe secrets ses secrets
ok mais du coup c'est un peu votre
réponse pour tous non merci encore à
vous dit bhl d'avoir bien voulu
sponsorisé cette vidéo est d'avoir créé
cette offre vous avez les deux mois
gratuits donc les deux titres audio
gratuit
en passant par le lien qu'il ya dans la
description est encore une fois monsieur
la bonne occasion pour prendre des
livres gratuitement
je fais des petits commerces là je dis à
tous ne pas payer mes livres et bd
prenant gratuitement buffett ça bon déjà
je tenais à remercier l'agent j qui a
préparé cette cette vidéo j comme jérémy
des tout le monde parce qu'en fait les
vidéos agent secret je kiffe aussi parce
que je découvre en même temps que vous
ce qui a été préparé quelle est la
mission est tout donc c'est beaucoup
trop cool merci à vous si vous avez aimé
la vidéo n'oubliez pas de faire comme
monsieur lavit de liker ce qui paraît
qu'il ait fait beaucoup de choses
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner tel
monsieur cocu et d'activer la cloche
comme l'aurait fait monsieur bordel ici
je vous mets deux autres vidéos
la première vidéo agent secret et une
autre vidéo sur la voie que j'avais
enregistrée il ya très longtemps avec
super plaignent que je vous mets juste
là pour apprendre à faire les voix des
bogdanov et s'est dit toi dans les
commentaires un peu comment vous en êtes
sortis sous les traits de sa phase il
dure que j'ai trouvé ça entre le dur et
le nordmann mais c'était hyper
intéressant à faire avec moi si vous
avez qui fait ça à très bientôt
charles